can i ask you about some other weird
particles
that make up our universe what are
axions
and uh what is the strong cp problem
okay
so uh let me start with what the strong
cp problem is
uh first of all well charge con
c is charge conjugation which is the
transformation uh the notional
transformation if you like that changes
all particles into their anti-particles
and the concept of c
symmetry charge conjugation symmetry is
that if you do that
you find the same laws that would work
uh so the laws are symmetric if
the behavior that particles exhibit is
the same as the part
as the behavior you get with all their
anti-particles
that then p is parody
which is uh also called spatial
inversion
it's basically looking at a mirror
universe
and saying that the laws that are obeyed
in a mirror universe when you look
the the mirror images obey the same laws
as the
as the sources of their images there's
no way of telling left
right for instance that the laws don't
distinguish between left and right
uh now in the mid 20th century
people discovered that both of those are
not quite true
that really the the equation that the
mirror universe
the universe that's that you see
in a mirror is not
going to obey the same laws as the uh as
the
the uh the universe that that that we
actually exhibit uh
and interpret you could you would be
able to tell if you
did the right kind of experiments which
was the mirror and which was the real
thing
uh anyway that that's the parody and
they show that the very tip doesn't
necessarily hold
it doesn't quite hold and that that oh
that and
examining uh what the exceptions are
turned out to be to lead to all kinds of
insight about
the nature of fundamental interactions
especially properties of neutrinos and
the weak interaction it's a long story
but it's a very very it's a so you just
define the c
and the p the conjugation the charge
conjugation now that i've done that i
want to
what's the problem shove them off okay
great
because it's easier to talk about t
which is time reversal symmetry
we have very good reasons to think
cpt is a an accurate
symmetry of nature it's on the same
level as relativity and quantum
mechanics basically so
that better be true uh so however
symmetric when you when you do
conjugation parity in time
and time and space reversal if you do
all three
then you get the same physical
consequences now
so but that means that cp is equivalent
to t
but but what's observed in the world is
that t is not quite an accurate symmetry
of nature
either so most phenomena
uh of at the fundamental level
so interactions among elementary
particles and the basic
gravitational interaction uh
if you ran them backwards in time
you'd get the same laws so if
again going unless this time we don't
talk about a
a mirror but we talk about a movie if
you take a movie
and then run it backwards
that's the time reversal uh it's cool to
think about a mirror
in time yes like a mirror in time if you
uh
if you run run the movie backwards it
would look very strange
if you were looking at complicated
objects and
uh you know a charlie chaplin movie or
whatever
they it would look very strange if you
ran it backwards in time
but at the level of basic interactions
if you were able to look at the atoms
and the
and the quarks involved they would obey
the same laws
they do a very good approximation but
not exactly
so you this is not exactly that means
you could tell you could tell
but you'd have to do very very subtle
experiments with at high energy
accelerators
to take a movie that looked different
when you ran it backwards
this was a discovery by
the two great physicists named cronin
and
jim cronin and val fitch in the uh
in the mid 1960s previous to that over
all the centuries of development of
physics with all his precise laws
they did seem to have this gratuitous
property
that they look the same if you run the
equations backwards it's a it's kind of
an embarrassing property actually
because
life isn't like that so empirical
reality does not have this imagery
in any obvious way and yet the laws did
it's almost like the laws of physics are
missing something fundamental about life
if if if it holds that property right
well i mean that's
that's the embarrassing nature it's it's
yeah it's embarrassing well people
worked hard and at what's
this was a problem that's thought to
belong to the foundations of statistical
mechanics or the
foundations of thermodynamics to
understand
how behavior which is
grossly not symmetric
with respect to reversing the direction
of time in large objects how that can
emerge from equations which
are symmetric with respect to changing
the direction of time to a very good
approximation and that's
that's still an interesting endeavor
that's that's that's interesting and
uh actually it's an exciting frontier of
physics now to sort of explore the
boundary between
when that's true and when it's not true
when you get to smaller objects
uh and exceptions like time crystals or
uh
i definitely have to ask if i time
crystals in a second here but all right
so the cp
problem and t so there's lost all of
these
we're in danger of infinite regress but
we'll convert soon
so can't possibly be turtles all the way
down we're gonna get to the bottom
turtle so
so so it became so it
it got to be a real i mean it's a really
puzzling thing
uh why the laws should have this very
odd property that we don't need
and in fact it's kind of an
embarrassment
in addressing empirical reality but it
seemed to be
almost it seemed to be exactly true for
a long time and then
uh almost true and
in way almost true was even is more
disturbing than exactly true
because exactly true it could have been
just a fundamental feature of the world
and you know at some level you just have
to take it as it is and if it's
if it's a beautiful easily articulatable
regularity you could say that okay
that's a that's
fine as a fundamental law of nature but
to say that it's approximately true but
not exactly that's
that's right that's weird so uh
and then so there was great progress
in uh the late part of the 20th century
uh in getting to an understanding of
fundamental interactions in general
that shed light on this issue uh
it turns out that the prince of basic
principles of relativity
and quantum mechanics plus the kind of
high degree of symmetry that we found
the so-called gauge symmetry that
characterizes the fundamental
interactions when you put all that
together
it's a very very constraining framework
and it has some indirect consequences
because the
possible interactions are so constrained
and one of the indirect consequences
is that the possibilities for
violating the symmetry between forwards
and backwards in time are very limited
they're basically only two
and one of them occurs and leads to a
very rich theory that explains the
cronin fish experiment and a lot of
things that have been done subsequently
has been used to
make all kinds of successful predictions
so that's that's turned out to be a very
rich
interaction it's esoteric and the
effects are
only show up at accelerators and are
small and so on but they might have been
very important in the early universe and
lead to them be connected to the
asymmetry between matter and anti-matter
in the present universe and so but
that's a that's another digression
the the point is that uh that was fine
that was a triumph
to say that there was one possible kind
of interaction that would violate
time reversal symmetry and sure enough
there it is and
but the other kind
doesn't occur so we still got a problem
why doesn't it occur
uh but we're so we're close to really
finally understanding this profound
gratuitous feature of the world
that is almost but not quite
symmetric under reversing the direction
of time but but not quite there
and uh to get to understand that last
bit
is a challenging frontier of physics
today
and we have a promising proposal for how
it works
which is a kind of theory of evolution
so there's this possible
interaction which we call a coupling and
there's a numerical quantity
that tells us how strong that is and
traditionally in physics we think of
these kinds of numerical
quantities as constants of nature
that uh you you just have to put them in
right that from experiment they have a
certain value and that that's it and you
know
who am i to question when god do it
they seem to be just constants
but in this case
it's been fruitful to think
and work out a theory where
that strength of interaction
[Music]
is actually not a constant it's a
fun it's a field it's a it's a
fields are the fundamental ingredients
of modern physics like
there's an electron field there's a
photon field which is also called the
electromagnetic field and so
every all of these particles are
manifestations of different fields
and uh there could be a field
something that depends on space and time
so a dynamical entity
instead of just a constant here
and uh if you do things in a nice
way that's very symmetric very much
suggested
aesthetically by the theory uh but but
the theory we do have
then you find that you get
a field which
as it evolves from the early universe
settles down to a value
that's just right
to make the laws very nearly
exact invariant or symmetric with
respect to reversal of time it might
appear as a constant but it's actually a
field that evolved over time it evolved
over time
okay but when you examine this proposal
in detail you find that it hasn't quite
settled down to exactly zero there it's
still
the the field is still moving around a
little bit
and because the motion is so
uh the motion is so difficult
the the material is so rigid and this
mysterio that feels all the field that
fills those spaces so rich
even small amounts of motion can involve
lots of energy
that and that energy takes the form
of uh particles fields of fields that
are in motion are always associated with
particles
and those are the axions and if you
calculate how much
energy is in these residual oscillations
these this axion gas that fills all the
universe if this fundamental theory is
correct
you get just the right amount to make
the dark matter that astronomers want
and it has just the right properties so
i'd love to believe
that so that might be a thing that
unlocks
uh might be the key to understanding
dark matter
yeah i'd like to think so and many many
physicists are coming around to this
point of view which
i've been a voice in the wilderness i
was a voice in the wilderness
for a long time but now now it's become
very popular maybe even dominant
so almost like so this axion
particle slash field would be
the thing that explains dark matter it
explains yeah would solve this
fundamental question
of finally of why the laws are
almost but not quite exactly
the same if you run them backwards in
time and and then
seemingly in a totally different
conceptual universe
it would also uh provide unders give us
an understanding of of the dark matter
that's not what it was
designed for and the theory wasn't
wasn't proposed with that in mind
but when you work out the equations
that's what you get that's always a good
sign
yeah actually uh i i think i've vaguely
read
uh somewhere that there may be early
experimental validation
of uh uh of axion is that uh
am i am i reading the wrong well there
have been
quite a few false alarms and i think
there are some of them still
i mean people desperately want to find
this thing and
uh but i don't think i i don't think any
of them are convincing at this point but
there are
very ambitious experiments
and uh kind of new you have to design
new kinds of antennas that are capable
of detecting
these predicted particles and it's it's
very difficult they interact very very
weakly if
it were easy it would have been done
already but um
but i think there's good hope that uh we
can get down to the required sensitivity
and actually test whether these ideas
are right or in coming
years or maybe decades and then
understand one of the big mysteries
like literally big in terms of uh its
fraction of the universe is dark matter
yes
you